are we talking about modularity and
sadly
so the two terms in the title modularity
and sampling let's begin by defining or
nearly defining those so modularity is
this measure from network science and
the idea is it gives you
a sort of a measure of how well a graph
can give you clusters so you've got your
graph g
and you've got a vertex partition on
that graph each vertex expectation gets
a score and then the modularity of your
graph is the max over all possible
vertex partitions of this
okay it will give you a value between
zero and one um i said it's from network
science so the idea is that these higher
values blessed one
are taken to indicate that the graph has
more community structure and
values closer to zero taken to indicate
sort of a lack of
community structure
and what we'll mean this time by
sampling is is literally the sampling
edges so you can imagine you've got some
underlying graph that you can't
necessarily see right but you get access
to the graph in the sense that
you see you have this observed graph and
there each edge on the bottom graph
appears independently with probability p
okay so you get to see the vertex set
and
in particular you don't get any sort of
false positive so there are no edges in
the top graph which didn't appear in the
bottom one get a subset
cool and so the question is right how
high do we have to make this p to get a
good estimate
on the on the graph so you can imagine
so
uh in this picture here um if you
plotted likely values of the
modularity of the observed graph what
we're aiming for is so of course for p
equals one we win right because the
observed graph is just exactly
the underlying graph but um how high do
we have to make this p value before we
get within this bound likely get within
this epsilon there
of the sort of modularity of the
underlying graph
and so
for something to be um a good estimate
it has to sort of not overestimate and
not underestimate
the thing you're trying to get and it
turns out this problem has um different
thresholds for these
okay well we we require different things
and so um
here
um
so this this is our graph again so we
can think about so people's one we're
here and the idea is that
for this sort of quite mild condition so
if if this this bit here holds so
if the um
think about it this is asking that the
expected number of edges is bigger than
some big constants than when it's long
so this is the number of edges in your
underlying graph and p is the
probability with which you see each one
if that holds then we don't
underestimate the modularity we may
overestimate it
um and then if we go a bit further quite
a bit further there's quite a strong
condition right so this is asking
actually that instead
of the number of edges being bigger than
uh some constant you actually want
the average degree to be bigger than
some constant
so then we can say that you're actually
you know estimating
you're in here
right
um and this theorem also gives us the
following so so you've got your
um observed graph and you might have
some high modularity partition of that
graph and so then you can construct what
must be a high modularity uh partition
at the bottom
in indian time so this is this is sort
of
something that actually makes sense
um with with the idea that these high
modularity uh partitions actually
indicates some good grouping of the data
data into these uh clusters
so
um
if your underlying graph was complete
graph then this model is i'm just
telling you about the error training or
binomial random graph right where each
edge is independent with probability p
and we know quite a bit about the
modularity of that and that tells you
actually that you really do uh need this
condition
as well
this condition you need for sort of more
basic reasons so
for some graphs at least these
conditions are tight
and so some simulations of this uh
we've taken as our underlying network
the dolphin network which came out of
the
phd pieces of gazelle
so this has 62 vertices 152 edges
and um
it's it's very nice there there's some
cool stories uh behind the clustering of
this network so people are interested in
it and it's known that the modularity
value
is uh within the decimal points the mod
modularity value is known
um
okay and we we can sort of actually uh
simulate this right so what we're
showing here is the different edge
probabilities
um we're going to sample 50 times there
should be 50 red dots above each of
these edge probabilities
a random graph
sorry
a sample where we we see each edge in
the dolphin network with probability p
and then i've said it's an estimate of
the modularity um because
to cloud continuity actually we had
modularity and so
we've um run the levain algorithm which
is what people sort of typically do a
number of times to get um
a good
or hopefully good the highest the
highest thing we can find the highest
scoring partition we could find and
that's what we've been plotted here
and you can see then
each of these are is either it's an
underestimate but possibly the um
correct value of the modularity of that
sample okay so you can see it is
actually uh
seems to be this uh trend where um under
sampling the network leads to over
estimating the modularity
and this was noticed actually in
ecological networks so in the kind of
network where you're saying in the field
and noticing when insects land on
flowers or something then you have a
really good idea of
um sort of sub samples right because you
have each each measurement comes with a
particular timestamp and so you can
imagine what you thought the graph was
at each particular time
and
you can work out so you should for
example
um uh
chip that um
the the graph parameter you're
interested in say modularity is actually
converging uh
as you're taking more and more samples
to check that you've uh taken enough
samples so in in this field it was
noticed that when you're under sampled
you seem to get too high
yeah yeah the there's no line for five
one point five two nine here right or
maybe maybe it's too thin i don't see it
is it basically the median of your last
i'll mark that next time thanks yes
i think because the network is so small
yeah 0.9 is still a little bit uh
undersampled but you're right it's
pretty much there yeah
and so um i put off uh the actual
definition of modularity it's not it's
not too bad okay so i'd say you've got
the graph you get a score for each
partition the modularity is a max of the
scores
over all partitions
and so the idea is it's um sort of get
rewarded for the proportion of edges
which show within your parts and you get
uh a penalty missing for the degree tax
and sort of penalizes if you've got two
big parts or too few parts
so here e of a is just the number of
edges holding within a uh the volume of
a is the sum of the degrees
and m is the total number of edges so
this here is a proportion of edges that
form within parts
and this this this here is your penalty
term
so people who prefer to think of it in a
sort of statistical physics way um this
is getting closer to that
so you can imagine so now here each part
is a spin
so you could also rewrite this so this
is an indicator that there's an edge
between u and v this is the degree of u
something very v
and so you could also write this as a
sum of all possible uv and replace this
with an indicator that u and v are in
the same path
right so this this i think is nice um
i'll talk through the first one because
i think it gives sort of helps helps out
absorb the definition so the idea is if
you have a graph and you've got some
vertex partition on that how can you
modify the graph slightly and hopefully
um get the modularity to increase
so the first one is saying you take your
graph your partition and pick two parts
and you take two edges which used to be
between the parts and put them inside
the parts so you'd hope the modularity
increase it does and this is just
checking the definition right so here's
here's an example they had two edges
here
another within the parts
so the modularity does go up right
because the number of edges stay the
same but the proportion within the parts
has gone up but
um the degrees
so
the sum of the volumes are of some of
the degrees i.e the volumes of each part
is still the same now so
um the modulators
well it's also uh
rested mostly just to um wet your
appetite so these crosses indicate that
these modifications do not always um
cause an increase in the modularity
so here's an example
like adding edges within parts will not
always give you um an increase in one
size yes you've got this at an edge it
dips down and then back up again
great so modularity
robust it's the the optimal partition is
not necessarily robust this can change
drastically by adding an edge but the
value itself is robust
so we said it's a value between zero and
one and if you delete say
okay and
again it's between zero and one so this
is highly modular or meant to have um a
good community structure
so this is true if you sort of
disconnected or nearly disconnected
small parts
it's also true if you sort of don't have
expansion so if there's no linear size
uh sub subgraph
which
is an expander
and you get really low um
modularity values um
relative community structure
with these conditions hold for example
so the spectral gap of the laplacian
being burst
very small
and this is again uh theorem
so i think if i have a minute or two i'd
run through some
open questions
um so the first one um is quite
interested to know the following so here
we're working
with um the urdish rainy random graph so
you've got
uh
n vertices and uh some constant on and
probability of each edge
and so we can think about the
expected value of the modularity of that
uh random graph
okay and so the question is does it tend
to a limit so surely it does right but
we can't prove it
um i mean theoretically
it could be higher near near squares or
something like this but i mean surely it
does and if we knew that then we'd be
able to say quite a lot about the
function
some sort of older results would be able
to
say a little bit about the decay of the
function so you sort of modulate the
value start high and then go down
and
um this last result would give us um
that it's um non-increasing
so i'd be interested if people want to
think about this
and we also have a conjecture which
comes from physics so the idea here is
that possibly the
maximum modularity can be gained by
taking a petition with just five parts
so i mean this is it's not strictly true
unfortunately because
so for example um if
you you have a um learning a number of
isolated edges and these should all
go into their own parts okay so it's not
fine right but it's it it could be that
this is true up to first order
this is also not quite true
um
because sort of for any particular c
you're going to have some
um significant proportion of your edges
outside this giant right in in these and
so that will benefit from having more
parts to allow you to break it up a bit
further um
you also have to be careful not to say
it uh
phrase the conjecture in a way in which
it's trivially true um but we think this
is a kind of the spirit
of the conjecture above
and so the question is like is there
some finite number of parts any finite
number would be interesting for us but
maybe it's five
such that for any error you if your c is
big enough then you really can um
approximate it with that constant number
of one parts
thank you cheers
any questions
yeah another question so uh in this
theory that you were showing you have
like the regimes yeah
i mean in a way it's dependent like it's
possible if your graph is uh too sparse
then you can never fulfill this
condition
and then and then um
um
um i mean so this
guess what this qrc is
i guess
it's
so it would be
it's not this right it says fast reading
i've really
another question here what you try to
estimate so i guess it's a probabilistic
question that you're addressing which is
like i want to estimate the uh
modularity and i just plug in the
modularity of my observations but yes
you know it's systematically biased
upwards yeah are there any better
estimators that people have proposed
that's a good question
thanks
we
we didn't realize it would be a
consistent thing until we started
thinking about it really hard right so
but yeah
and sorry you had a question yeah so
maybe it's nonsense i'm not an expert in
modularity but if i remember correctly
it's somehow equivalent to an eigenvalue
problem of the adjacency matrix
of the graph this pointer transformation
that if this is maybe
yeah exactly if this is true i think one
could um try to use um
spectral results for for the graph
laplacian um to also attack this
modularity problem because the graphical
version is basically the same as the
jesus image up to the unit matrix
then maybe looking into these techniques
um might also know
everything we can show it's um an upper
bound
yeah get up and down for a minute
but you can
the laplacian's not robust i think so
you can change a few edges and share the
different um
uh spectral gaps a little faster yeah
for sure they are not the same thing
yeah no no no no no no no no no no no no
yeah yeah you can rewrite the problems
into each other so yeah
all right so that's like uh